let's start off with some of the top
respiratory illnesses that we're seeing
this time of year
well it's it really mostly like any
other year we're certainly seeing colds
allergies are going to be on the
downslide right now they tend to be
more in the spring summer and a little
bit in the fall but as things get colder
we actually see a decrease in allergies
of course what makes this year so much
different is our
unfortunately increasing levels of
coca-19
absolutely and that makes sense with the
allergies and you know say
you know you wake up one morning you're
really not feeling well is it
covid the flu is it potentially
lingering allergies you know
what is that process of elimination
there that people should be doing
i think there's there's a few ways to
distinguish between
uh these different conditions i will say
up front that it's not so easy to
distinguish between
uh particularly early on uh influenza
the regular seasonal flu and cobia 19
there's a tremendous amount of overlap
in those
in those kinds of symptoms but that said
when we talk about
you know certainly uh colds and
allergies
and and it's important if we're trying
to help people figure out
should they seek medical attention and
let me say that
if someone feels they need medical
attention they should go get medical
attention they shouldn't be afraid of
going
doctors offices hospitals emergency
departments or being very careful about
protecting patients
um in these unusual times even more so
than
than we do on regular days but in terms
of colds and allergies i mean the
biggest clue
i will offer up in terms of allergies
and people often overlook this is
is this something you've had before does
it happen around this time of year
or if you're around these kinds of of
triggers things like
pet dander from cats and dogs and
ferrets for that matter
and cockroaches also are a big trigger
for
allergies but then there's also
environmental allergies
um things in the air from you know
pollens and grasses and again
those sorts of things are going to be
taping off this this time of year
but is this something that happens to
you all the time i mean is it you know
every march you get this runny nose i
think you know that's
uh that's a big piece um allergies and
colds tend to be
relatively mild they're annoying and
they're incredibly unpleasant
um but people tend not to feel really
beaten down
by those kinds of symptoms
distinguishing between the two
uh again if you've got experience with
allergies you know things like
the itchy eyes um and sort of the
constant clear runny nose um very common
with allergies
with colds you tend to feel you know
very congested particularly
in the nose and not so much down in the
chest
mild cough but not really producing
anything and those things can generally
be treated
in adults with over-the-counter
medications
um in very young children younger than
school age
the evidence is pretty clear that those
over-the-counter medications
typically don't help very much and there
are some side effects from those so
in very young kids we recommend not
using over-the-counter medications
for colds the other a big indicator is
fever
occasionally people can get a mild fever
with colds
uh but if that fever is particularly
elevated we're talking about
you know 101 fahrenheit or more
that's not something we usually see with
a cold or with allergy so that pushes us
more toward
whether this is uh the flu or pneumonia
potentially
um so when we start talking about those
other
uh more significant illnesses the flu
pneumonia
we're talking about really feeling much
much sicker people with the flu tend to
have
a lot of body aches tend to have a lot
of fatigue
um again it's the same kinds of
respiratory symptoms with the cough
often a runny nose um and again i made
the reference to the fever already
pneumonia is much more chest based
symptoms you can get some
some runny nose but it's really about
that cough that comes from deep in the
chest
and pneumonia much more likely doesn't
happen all the time but much more
likely to have a productive cough you're
actually coughing something up
um i would caution parents that that
children tend not to cough things up
they tend to swallow that before we ever
see
it but you can often hear that you hear
that rattle as opposed to that dry cough
you see and then when it comes to
distinguishing that
between covid where does that come into
play
well again the the distinction between
covet and influence is
very difficult on a clinical basis
that's that's something
for which we really need to test and one
of the things that's really important
about this that can help
uh not just to make the distinction but
to prevent people from dealing with
those more significant illnesses
those for which they may need to seek
medical attention whether it's
whether it's influenza or cobit or
pneumonia
is preventive measures uh it's really
important that folks who are eligible
get
vaccine for for influenza every year
and it's really important that folks who
who are eligible
get their immunization for pneumonia
and i will say the cdc has excellent
information on their website
that defines who should and shouldn't
get it and there's actually a very
small portion of the population um who
meet the age requirements but
but otherwise shouldn't get it so you
know really if
uh you know if you meet the age
qualification for influenza
um that's just about everybody outside
of infants
you know it's something you should get
unless you've had a
life-threatening reaction to one of the
components of the vaccine
it's highly advisable for you to get it
now it's
important for folks to understand that
you know the vaccines are
very good but they're not 100 effective
no vaccine is 100 effective and if folks
are looking for one thing
that will prevent influenza will prevent
pneumonia will prevent
covid they're going to be disappointed
because we won't find that and the key
is really to do as many of the things as
we can
to layer on top of one another to
decrease the risk and certainly for a
lot about that
with regard to covid this year we do not
yet have an approved covid vaccine
but there are a lot of things that we
can be doing to prevent
our risk of getting code 19 and that
includes certainly
mask wearing any time that you're out
and around people who don't live in your
household it includes social
distancing includes minimizing the
amount of time you spend out
only to the essentials and that's
frankly why we're having this
conversation this way rather than
uh in the studio somewhere because you
know we can make this work it's is it
ideal
it's not but we can make this work and
this decreases the risk to you
and to me of the transmission of coba to
19
that carries over to things like
influenza we would
expect that if people are are following
the guidelines to decrease their risk
for
covid we should also see some decrease
in transmission of influenza which would
be a great thing it's a serious disease
and it does cause deaths in this country
every year absolutely and you know kind
of touching back on the immunizations
you know how how does that affect um
you know not overwhelming our hospital
system especially
as we're trying to fight
covid right now especially with the flu
vaccine
well again just with with as it is with
about everything else
prevention is always better
um if we can prevent someone from
getting sick we can keep someone healthy
or even if the vaccine isn't 100
effective to prevent someone from
getting sick
at all but it can decrease the severity
of the illness
then that decreases the pressure on the
health care system
if somebody has mild flu symptoms
because they got a vaccine and although
it didn't
prevent them from catching it entirely
it made the illness very mild
for one they won't need any any serious
intervention and
and perhaps more importantly they won't
be down as long they'll be able to get
back to their lives or be able to get
back to work to be able to
uh to get back to their family and and
those sorts of things
um so that prevention i can't emphasize
that enough
uh to take the steps that we can get the
immunizations unless you have
one of the very few conditions uh that
uh that make that
uh something that you shouldn't take and
again the cdc's web page has a
great information to be very clear about
the conditions that someone could
should avoid those vaccines or even
consider avoiding those vaccines and
discuss with their with their healthcare
professional
and kind of touching back on you know
covet and the flu and kind of that fine
line between them so say
you are experiencing some of those very
similar symptoms
and uh like you said you know it kind of
comes down to testing is
if somebody is feeling that though is
that a situation where
they go get a test on their own they
call their primary care physician
they how would they handle that yeah
the best thing if possible is to
coordinate through their primary care
physician a a huge number of primary
care
practices have telemedicine available so
you may be able to do this
exactly as we're having our conversation
now and be able to make that decision
about uh about how to go about doing
that uh
whether someone you know heads to any of
the sites that are offering covet
testing or if they come into the office
uh to uh to be assessed first and
potentially test it there
if the testing is available in that
office so
keeping your primary care provider in
the loop and working
with them collaboratively is always the
best way
to make sure that you're getting the
best care and also you may have mild
symptoms now
and they they can give you some
indications about all right what are the
thresholds for when you should
call me back now i i will say that
people should look out for
more severe symptoms uh very high fever
that's persistent uh you know we're
talking fever over 100 200 two and a
half fahrenheit
uh in adults kids tolerate a bit higher
than that um
but if it's persistent i mean if it
spikes up one day and then comes down
and they're feeling okay
um i don't think they need to get too
worried but if it's persistent over a
couple of days
they probably want to have somebody take
a look at them
and again reaching out to their primary
care providers is a good way they have
any difficulty breathing
mild cough is one thing but if it's
actually hard to breathe
they want to to get themselves seen
folks with flu can have aches and pains
all over
but if somebody feels severe chest pain
particularly
very localized chest pain in one spot
they definitely want to
want to come in and make sure they're
evaluated that's something that's
pretty consistent with the pneumonia um
so we want to make sure to rule that out
if
if they're experiencing those symptoms
um so those are really some of the big
ones that would trigger
someone to to reach out
and and have themselves evaluated by
healthcare professionals
it really seems like having an open
communication with your primary care
physician
is a good way to handle flu season
pneumonia season and the time of cobit
it's it's a good rule all the time uh
the better your communication is with
your primary care provider
the better you can anticipate uh what
you need to do
uh make sure that you get uh you know
sort of locked into preventive uh
care uh for normal screenings that
you're gonna need
uh we all that we all need um you know
as we get older
uh routine screenings to identify things
before they become a problem
that kind of open communication is
incredibly important and that really is
the role
of primary care provider whether it's a
pediatrician like me or
it's a family medicine doctor or an
internist or for older folks a
specialist in in the elderly
geriatrician
and let's talk a bit about flu season in
general for
this year um you know from your point of
view how has that been going so far has
some of the coveted
uh precautions and restrictions impacted
uh the impact of flu season at all i
think it's a little early to say
we're just really getting into the time
for the
the regular flu season um so i i
wouldn't hazard a guess
at the moment again from a theoretical
standpoint if folks are doing the things
that we've been recommending that they
do to decrease
the spread of covid it should also help
to decrease the spread of influenza
and so it seems like this is this is
really the time to be on the lookout if
you know as we head
into flu season to make sure you
understand
the different symptoms and what they may
be yeah
absolutely and again you know taking
those preventive measures that
that are good for all of these uh to
reduce the risk of all of these uh
conditions
getting an influenza vaccine getting a
pneumonia vaccine
you know if you qualify for those that's
really important and when i say
qualify that's that's a medical
determination based on your age and your
medical conditions and things like that
folks can find all that information at
the cdc's website is there anything that
i didn't ask about that you think is
really important for
our viewers to understand as we deal
with covid and the flu and pneumonia and
all that
again i'm gonna risk sounding like a
broken record here the two biggest
things
are one take the preventive measures
that you can
uh wear a mask when you're out social
distance decrease the amount of time
that you're out to those things that are
absolutely essential uh
and get the vaccines uh that you need
for influenza or pneumonia or both
and then the other is if you feel like
you need to be assessed by
a healthcare professional do it don't
wait it's okay
everybody's taking precautions to make
sure that patients and staff
and and the professionals are safe and
we want to make sure that people are
getting the care that they need before
things get really bad so
those are the most important messages